êtes vous fans d'harry potter ou encore
de gandalf et ils ont des pouvoirs
magiques qui leur permet de faire par
exemple ceci voilà par contre sur le
tournage c'est comme moi c'est ridicule
eh bien mon ami en fusionnant les deux
tu obtiens mirage harkat noir alors
alors alors on va aller sur un petit 10
v10 j'ai fait qu'une seule game mont
gangan âgées gré il ya un perso que tout
le monde prend lui balaie hilali
personnes là ok on est les rouges
donc j'ai d'esquisser quoi mais ce qu'il
a je peux vomir avec mon bâton c'est pas
mal je peux voler ah non d'avec le khat
est le jeu avant d'y jouer [ __ ] f
ah ah ah ouai c'est trop bien et mon mot
clic droit c'est la majorette d'accord
au québec c'est parti on va casser dès
qu il nous a paru laissez moi laissez
moi laissez moi mais je me fais vite je
me fais victimes puisque dans la chasse
derrière problème on attend 1re v1 ou
pas mais mais pourquoi
bon les amis de façon si je perds cette
simple c'est que ce personnel est pas il
est ouvrier pas ouf
tu vois il est pas dingue on va prendre
et elle la voleuse à l ai bien l bon mec
on est les rouges il ya double en bas
mais flore la montée quel patron jamais
une mauvaise image sur la mine marche où
il est surtout le mec est trop fort
tiens tiens très bien pour les amis j'ai
pris un perso je sais jouer pour essayer
de faire rêver un petit peu ma
communauté
lui je le connais c'est le sérieux que
je connais et ça c'est très bien parce
qu'ils lancent des sorts comme ça ok on
va envoyer un gros lag règles et là on
se tapait derrière là bas on se tapait
la barre
hop là on en voit un truc de zone le
débat rouiba boulbon moi j'attends ici
le mec qui osera me prend dans un verre
qui représentera son pop qui vient
envers toi
au delà je me tais paie commande les
browns juste moi j'ai fait en fait
émerger plus de sorts j'ai plus de sorts
je le renvoie
pardon moi je vais là-bas alors c'est
parti il faut capturer les deux mig leaf
2009 c'est parti on prend dans sa
couette est mort tard été muté et mon
[ __ ] c'est bien mal me plaît ça vous a
plu
ce n'est que le début hop là oh là là
mais quel ton attention va aider l'avion
va aider la liant difficulté [ __ ] et
chaude attentats au nom au [ __ ] mais
la meuf elle et c'est un ninja secret du
japon ça entraîné depuis des années par
des moines ne suis pas du tout un drame
d'hier le scénario de iron fist au
québec ça manque de punch pingisi voilà
ça va aller mieux avatar le psycho la
grotte le micro moi tout je m'en vais
soit padeg casse toi à sebha tête j'ai
cru que c'était un pouf au début ça va
tu es très bien bon on va pas se mentir
il ya du ski l'enfance mais bon c'est le
temps de s'habituer je peux vous dire
qu'après on va mieux se gérer ce bâton
qu une majorette
elle est là c'est elle qui m'a tuer ça
marchait têtu mais avec la gravité aux
attendes mais devait arriver ce qu'on
peut faire de garder un moment s'il vous
plaît la seule fois je me suis vexé dans
ma vie j'avais cette tête et cette voix
là j'ai perdu tous mes amis en coupe on
a gagné on a gagné de l'xp on est
dernier mais comment d'hakkari on a
carry la game on va reprendre lui lui en
vrai mais qui défonce avec son bâton là
il me fait rêver
ok je me soignais au je vais te renvoyer
aux halles et le combat nous appelle aux
morts morts oh je travaille je m'en bats
les couilles
moi aussi je peux voler n'est pas dans
l'air au ca batna absolue de tous les
temps
merci merci beaucoup
tu veux quoi tu veux que tu me suces la
jambe attend il trop forte c'est quoi
cet assassin regarder la trop forte je
suis amoureux je suis assez ça être
amoureux à bon dieu je t'aime mon amour
il a pris la fuite [ __ ] on va le
suivre on va le traquer les ouvrants
mondiaux mon amour tu l'as trouvé je te
soignes est mort tu peux pas lutter mon
amour là tu as deux ma puce via connard
l'ace map et sempé aux mapuches regard
ça fait trois ans qu'on tue en sommes à
faire des grandes choses je te suis bébé
ok je dois et des joies et des mes amis
des morts chronofoot un talus fausse de
faire léviter more mr j'ai défoncé
mandat mise en veille ce vrai voilà
voilà ce qui arrive on va bientôt gagner
est-ce que ça m'étonne non cette équipe
est extrêmement performante en même
temps en face ils sont un petit peu
trois fois dans nombreux et ouais les
amis et de courage je sais aussi quitté
son amoureuse pour aller voir
l'amoureuse d'en face c'est parti et ben
voila je sais pas si j'ai bien fait de
changer d'équipé mais je trouve que l'on
commence à avoir un petit niveau on
commence par un petit goût en faire quoi
on va retourner sur le serveur on était
au début on s'est fait démolir mon pote
tu peux dire que là ça va car c'est dès
qu on est les violets on doit tuer les
rouges c'est parti et si on jouer autre
chose que le vomito lui c'est quoi c'est
ce qu'il il pousse les nids comme ça et
mettez à force le mec ok il envoie une
boule géante et charges en mec c'est
drôle ça à rochejean l'ujtl chargé
[Applaudissements]
j'adore ce berceau à bon dieu
un des mecs mais ce qu'on fait c'est
cesser la foule il a attend s comme en
sélection n'a pas déjà fait des
meilleures choses que en dix minutes
avant oui allez on joue enfin j'adore ce
perso j'ai trouvé mon berceau
c'est certain que tu vois là quand tu
rentres ton perso c'est un peu pareil
que quand tu ton amoureux pour avoir
votre avis vraiment tu fait qu on est
millionnaire
ok ok ok pas non pas aux [ __ ]
excuse-moi de t'avoir fait un compliment
désolé je vais pas car un mec donc là on
va régler ça à la force de nos mains
voila voila explosé et voilà tant
d'efforts pour une belle défaite on
n'est pas dernier au le mec qui a tué
quatre mais qu'il est mort 12 fois la
pire vis dedans j'ai trouvé mon mail mon
gars j'ai trouvé mon match hyper
commencer un bon gros guerrier mon gars
et il représente tellement bien
physiquement
ok on est les oranje on espère les
violets c'est parti oh tu fais quoi
casse toi moi c'est quoi ça avec un
temps calme toi comme toi voilà voilà et
comme si ça ne suffisait pas de charge
oh
oh ce que je veux
le mec je lis explosé alors les violets
ont fait moins les malins d'un coup un
raté oh quelle belle acrobatie on va
appeler patrick sébastien vous qui
passez au cabaret des morts le jean
sinon je parle pas du lévis [ __ ] way
ses approvisionnements au monde sur ce
jeu cassez-vous pour moi hollebeke je
peux vicaut ce mec t'es mort franchement
je peux pas totaux penser mais en vrai
voilà à temps là on a fait un truc de
malade national en vertu de malade et
vous avez vu ou pas et puis non d'être
guéri à lézat mais on peut le faire on
peut le faire attention attention
regardez il ya du monde au bord du vide
ya du monde au balcon comme on dit
attention
j'aimerais voir ça tous les jours en me
levant le matin à tanger le choix entre
des skis il je suis con soit c'est le
trias que la force soit ces explosifs
punch power pool punch qui expose à
l'impact parce qu'on n'a pas envie de
dire oh là là mais attends mais tous les
skis qu'on n'avait pas pris son mieux
alors matc tout ça j'ai hâte de tester
le punch mais j'ai on va on va on
s'appelle one touch dans cette gamme
j'annonce ok toi c'est parti ah merde
le coup de poing au plat à temps mais le
gars qui fait quoi là mais il a la boule
et bill
et voila voila c'est sawan poche mon
gars le vide annonce pas du vide au
lemay qui porte et minutes c'était
vraiment lâche vient m'a dit tu es un
homme tu ne lâche pas je trahis mon gars
[Musique]
je veux vraiment emmener quelqu'un dans
le vide avec moi dans l'eau je vous
quitte le jeu tend une embuscade à des
embuscades dégage tu perdras de combats
toujours non pardon excusez moi j'ai
conduit aux commentaires
eh ben ça a marché ou pas un même
tournoi maillot rose que tu as tiennent
plus mon gars et bien voilà les amis
c'est la fin de tout de tout ces petits
tours de magie comme par exemple celui
ci voilà puis en magicien ne vais jamais
me voir en spectacle si je fais de la
magie n'hésitez pas et méline 2 ça vous
a plu en tout cas le jeu est très très
cool ça fait plaisir c'est vraiment
chivalry ce v2 avec des sorts et tout
s'est mieux foutu j'ai beaucoup aimé
mais je pense trimer sur ce jeudi dont à
la tranchée de mercenariat les sentez
vous bien sûr tout le monde
[Musique]
disons qu'ils sont